(quiet music)
Female: We're in the MoMA stores looking
at a poster of 1913 designed and printed
in Amsterdam by Louis Raemaekers.
This is a dramatic use
of very simple means,
two colors lithographically printed,
and it shows this new integrative approach
to the combination of image and text.
It's a political poster
which takes the form
of this giant creepy spider and web.
This is protesting the Tariff Act
that the Netherlandish government
had introduced raising levies on
the everyday products
featured in the poster.
You can see here the cocooned prey
of clothing, tools and food
that were subject to these tariffs.
The use of the spider feeds off
a quite visceral sense of discomfort
that we have with spiders.
What's new about Raemaekers' image
is that it really exploits
the kind of microscopic
scientific scrutiny of small insect life,
the hairy legs and the talons at the end
attached to this gossamer web.
This style of poster, the symbolic
and metaphorical use of animal life,
and the whole subject of tariffs
are indicative of the tensions,
both economic and aesthetic,
that would erupt during
the first World War.
Raemaekers' techniques using
animal political imagery
was so effective in World War I
that in fact the German government
put a bounty on his head
and he was forced to take flight
from Amsterdam for London.
(quite music)